LEGITIMATE LAWFUL TRANSFER OF
POWER FROM ONE ADMINISTRATION TO
THE NEXT.
>> AND ANOTHER SIGN THAT THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE IS GETTING
SEAR YE, THEY HAVE OBTAINED A
SEARCH WARRANT FOR THE PHONE OF
JOHN EASTMAN, THE CONSERVATIVE
LAWYER WHO WAS BEHIND THE
PRESSURE CAMPAIGN AGAINST FORMER
VICE PRESIDENT MIKE PENCE, OF
COURSE, SEVERAL WEEKS AGO,
FEDERAL INVESTIGATORS STOPPED
EASTMAN AND SEARCH ISSED HIM AT
THE TIME.
THEY OBTAINED HIS CELL PHONE AT
THAT TIME.
THIS IS NOW THEM ASKING A JUDGE
IF THEY CAN SEARCH THE PHONE,
SHOWING THAT THEY'RE VERY
INTERESTED IN THE ROLE THAT
EASTMAN PLAYED IN THE EFFORT TO
OVERTURN THE ELECTION RESULTS.
>> POTENTIALLY A VERY
SIGNIFICANT DEVELOPMENT AS WELL.
RYAN, STAY WITH US.
I WANT TO BRING IN CNN'S CHIEF
LEGAL ANALYST, JEFFREY TOOBIN,
AND SENIOR LEGAL ANALYST LAURA
COATES.
THIS WARRANT FOR JOHN EASTMAN'S
PHONE, COOPERATION FROM KEY
TRUMP WHITE HOUSE INSIDERS, WHAT
DOES IT SAY TO YOU WE'RE GETTING
ALL THESE NEW DETAILS RIGHT NOW
ABOUT THIS FEDERAL CRIMINAL
INVESTIGATION?
>> WELL, THIS IS REALLY A
DRAMATIC CHANGE FROM WHAT WE
KNEW FOR SURE JUST A FEW DAYS
AGO.
THERE HAD BEEN HINTS THAT THIS
INVESTIGATION HAS BEEN GOING ON
FOR MONTHS.
BUT NOW WE KNOW FOR CERTAIN.
AND THIS IS A VERY DIFFERENT
INVESTIGATION THAN THE ONE THAT
BROUGHT HUNDREDS OF PEOPLE TO BE
PROSECUTED FOR THE ACTUAL
INVASION OF THE CAPITOL.
THESE ARE CRIMES, IF THEY ARE
CRIMES, THAT TOOK PLACE IN THE
WHITE HOUSE, IN THE OVAL OFFICE.
THESE ARE INVESTIGATIONS OF THE
PRESIDENT AND THE PEOPLE
IMMEDIATELY AROUND HIM.
THAT'S CLEARLY NOW GOING ON.
WHETHER THERE WILL BE CRIMES
DISCLOSED, WHETHER THERE WILL BE
INDICTMENTS IS A SEPARATE
QUESTION, BUT THERE CAN'T BE
INDICTMENTS WITHOUT AN
INVESTIGATION, AND WE KNOW NOW
THERE IS AN INVESTIGATION.
>> LAURA, ACCORDING TO BOTH "THE
WASHINGTON POST" AND "THE NEW
YORK TIMES," FEDERAL PROSECUTORS
ARE ASKING SPECIFIC QUESTIONS
ABOUT FORMER PRESIDENT TRUMP
HIMSELF.
HOW SIGNIFICANT IS THAT?
>> IT'S VERY SIGNIFICANT.
NORMALLY WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
ASKING QUESTIONS NOT AS PART OF
A LET ME GET THE LAY OF THE
LAND, BUT THE SPECIFICITY TO ME
DESCRIBES THAT THEY HAVE ALREADY
HAD INFORMATION FROM OTHER
SOURCES.
MAYBE THEY'RE TRYING TO COMPARE
AND CONTRAST, FILL IN PARTICULAR
HOLES.
REMEMBER, JUST A FEW WEEKS AGO,
YOU HAD THE DOJ AND COMMITTEE
ENGAGED IN A LETTER CAMPAIGN
AGAINST ONE ANOTHER, NOT TRYING
TO BE ANTAGONISTIC, BUT THE IDEA
OF THE DOJ WANTING THE
INFORMATION THAT THE COMMITTEE
HAD, WANTING TO HAVE WHAT OTHER
TRANSCRIPTS THEY MAY HAVE.
WHY?
WE NOW KNOW IT'S LIKELY BECAUSE
THEY WERE TRYING TO ESSENTIALLY
DECIDE WHETHER THE PEOPLE THEY
HAVE EITHER ALREADY INTERVIEWED
OR INTEND TO DO SO WILL HAVE
CREDIBILITY ISSUES.
WHETHER IT'S CONSISTENT IN SOME
WAY.
YOU WANT TO DOT THOSE Is AND
CROSS THOSE Ts LOSE THE WAY.
TO HAVE SPECIFIC QUESTIONS OF
THE UNITED STATES SAYS THEY'RE
MUCH FARTHER ALONG IN TRYING TO
SUBSTANTIATE AND CORROBORATE AS
OPPOSED TO JUST GET FOUNDATIONAL
INFORMATION.
IT'S NOT THE BEGIN OF THE
INVESTIGATION, IN OTHER WORDS.
WE'RE VERY FAR ALONG.
>> HOW MUCH OF AN UPHILL BATTLE
WOULD THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT
FACE IF IT WERE TO DECIDE TO
FORMALLY OFFICIALLY INDICT THE
FORMER PRESIDENT, TRUMP?
>> IT WOULD BE A VERY COMPLEX
PROSECUTION.
ONE ISSUE THAT I THINK IS OFF
THE TABLE IS THE ONE OF CAN YOU
INDICT A SITTING PRESIDENT?
THAT IS A JUSTICE DEPARTMENT
POLICY GOING BACK TO THE NIXON
YEARS, WHICH SAYS YOU CAN'T
INDICT A SITTING PRESIDENT.
DONALD TRUMP IS NO LONGER A
SITTING PRESIDENT, SO I THINK
THAT ISSUE IS NOT GOING TO BE A
HINDRANCE TO THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT.
BUT THERE ARE VERY COMPLEX
CONSTITUTIONAL ISSUES HERE.
WHAT WAS FREE SPEECH ON THE PART
OF DONALD TRUMP AS OPPOSED TO A
CONSPIRACY TO ENGAGE IN ILLEGAL
ACTIVITY?
JOHN EASTMAN WAS PROVIDING LEGAL
ADVICE.
HOW MUCH LEGAL ADVICE IS WITHIN
THE AMBIT OF JUST TAKING A SHOT
AND HOW MUCH IS ACTUALLY
ENCOURAGING SOMEONE TO VIOLATE
THE LAW.
THOSE ARE VERY HARD QUESTIONS
THAT NEED TO BE RESOLVED.
BUT THE WAY YOU RESOLVE THOSE
QUESTIONS IS BY COLLECTING
EVIDENCE.
AND THAT'S HOT THEY'RE DOING.
AND ONCE THEY HAVE COLLECTED
ENOUGH EVIDENCE, THEY'LL DECIDE
IF THERE'S A PROSECUTABLE CASE.
>> LET ME FOLLOW UP WITH LAURA.
AS THIS INVESTIGATION CLEARLY
INCHING CLOSES AND CLOSER TO THE
FORMER PRESIDENT, WOULD TRUMP BE
MISTAKEN TO THINK ANOTHER
PRESIDENTIAL RUN COULD OFFER HIM
AT LEAST SOME PROTECTION FROM
LEGAL CONSEQUENCES?
>> YES, HE WOULD BE MISTAKEN.
REMEMBER, THE SORT OF UNSPOKEN
RULE AND ONE THAT IS PART OF THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT, IS TO NOT
PUT THEIR THUMBS ON THE SCALE OF
AN ACTUAL UPCOMING ELECTION.
NOT WANTING TO SOMEHOW INFLUENCE
VOTERS BY HAVING THE NOTION THAT
ONE IS GUILTY BY VIRTUE OF BEING
IN THE COURT OF PUBLIC OPINION
AND HAVING THAT PRESUMPTION OF
INNOCENCE NOT MEAN A LOT TO
VOTERS.
BUT REMEMBER, AS MUCH AS DONALD
TRUMP MAY BE CASTING A SHADOW
AND BE VERY INFLUENTIAL
PERSPECTIVELY ON HOW VOTERS LOOK
AT THE MIDTERMS, HE'S NOT
ACTUALLY ON THE BALLOT.
THE IDEA YOU HAVE ONCE BEEN A
PRESIDENT AND MIGHT ONCE RUN
AGAIN AS PRESIDENT, YOU WOULD
NOT HAVE THE IMMUNIZING FACTOR
INDEFINITELY TO SAY, HEY, AS
LONG AS YOU HAVE THE PROSPECT OF
RUNNING, YOU CAN NEVER BE HELD
TO ACCOUNT.
THAT WOULD BE A GRAVE ERROR AND
ONE THAT I HOPE HIS LAWYERS ARE
NOT INSTRUCTING HIM ON.
>> JUST TO ADD ONE POINT THERE.
MERRICK GARLAND WAS ASKED THAT
VERY QUESTION BY LESTER HOLT IN
HIS NBC INTERVIEW YESTERDAY.
AND GARLAND COULD NOT HAVE BEEN
CLEARER THAT THE FACT THAT
SOMEONE MIGHT BE RUNNING FOR
PRESIDENT IS NOT SOMETHING THAT
GETS HIM IMMUNITY FROM BEING
PROSECUTED.
I THINK THAT ISSUE REALLY IS OFF
THE TABLE.
>> NO ONE IS ABOVE THE LAW,
THAT'S WHAT HE HAS SAID BEFORE.
THAT'S THE GIST OF WHAT'S GOING
ON RIGHT NOW.
RYAN, I KNOW YOU'RE DOING A LOT
OF REPORTING ON THE HILL.
HOW ARE THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT
AND HOUSE SELECT COMMITTEE
NAVIGATING THESE OVERLAPPING
INVESTIGATIONS?
IT'S REALLY OBVIOUSLY A VERY
SENSITIVE ISSUE.
>> IT IS, WOLF, BUT IT DOES SEEM
AS IF THE COMMITTEE AND
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE HAVE KIND
OF PUT ASIDE THEIR DIFFERENCES
AND ARE NOW MUCH MORE
COOPERATIVE THAN THEY WERE IN
THE PAST.
COMMITTEE MEMBERS SAY THEY'RE
OPEN TO HELPING THE DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE AT ANY LEVEL THEY
CAN.
THEY'RE BEING VERY PROPRIETARY
OVER THE INFORMATION THEY HAVE
ALREADY UNCOVERED BUT THEY'RE
COMING UP WITH A SYSTEM TO ALLOW
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE TO
HAVE ACCESS TO THAT.
WE DON'T KNOW AT WHAT LEVEL THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE HAS
OBTAINED THAT INFORMATION, BUT
THEY'RE